THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
"AC 360" STARTS NOW.
>>> GOOD EVENING.
OBSTRUCTION OF CONGRESS,
CONSPIRACY TO DE FRAUD THE
UNITED STATES, AND INSURRECTION
ARE THE THREE CRIMINAL CHARGES
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE MAY
RECOMMEND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
PURSUE AGAINST FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP WHEN IT MEETS LIKELY FOR
THE LAST TIME ON MONDAY
ACCORDING TO SOURCES WHO SPOKE
WITH CNN TONIGHT.
OBVIOUSLY IT IS A BIG DAY IF AND
WHEN THAT OCCURS AFTER ALMOST 17
MONTHS OF INVESTIGATIONS AND
PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
THE COMMITTEE SPENT ALMOST A
YEAR AND A HALF COMPILING
EVIDENCE SHOW CASING THEIR
FINDINGS DURING OFTEN GRIPPING,
HOURS LONG PUBLIC HEARINGS THIS
YEAR.
OBSTRUCTION OF CONGRESS ALWAYS
AT THE FOREFRONT OF POSSIBLE
CHARGES.
MUCH OF IT CENTERED AROUND THE
PRESSURE ON FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION AS WELL AS THE PRESSURE
ON THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
>> YOU ALSO NOTED THAT MR. ROSEN
SAID TO MR. TRUMP, QUOTE, DOJ
CAN'T AND WON'T SNAP ITS FINGERS
AND CHANGE THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION.
HOW DID THE PRESIDENT RESPOND TO
THAT, SIR?
>> HE RESPONDED VERY QUICKLY AND
SAID ESSENTIALLY, THAT'S NOT
WHAT I'M ASKING YOU TO DO.
WHAT I'M JUST ASKING YOU TO DO
IS JUST SAY IT WAS CORRUPT AND
LEAVE THE REST TO ME AND THE
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMEN.
>> EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THE
SECOND CHARGE, CONSPIRACY TO
DEFRAUD, WAS PRESENTED ALMOST
FROM THE OUTSET IN THE FIRST
HEARING IN WHAT WE SHOULD WARN
YOU IS SOME DIRECT OFF COLOR
LANGUAGE PLAYING TESTIMONY BY
FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR ONE OF MANY WHO SAID
THEY REPEATEDLY TRIED TO TELL
THE FORMER PRESIDENT THERE WAS
NO FRAUD IN THE ELECTION.
IN OTHER WORDS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT KNEW OR SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN HIS ALLEGATIONS WERE
UNTRUE.
>> I MADE IT CLEAR I DID NOT
AGREE WITH THE IDEA OF SAYING
THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN AND
PUTTING OUT THIS STUFF WHICH I
TOLD THE PRESIDENT WAS BULL
SHIT.
>> AS FOR THE THIRD CHARGE
INSURRECTION THE COMMITTEE CITED
TESTIMONY BY RALLY GOERS AS WELL
AS THE PRESIDENT'S OWN WORDS TO
ESTABLISH HIS CULPABILITY FOR
THE RIOT.
>> HE PERSONALLY ASKED US TO
COME TO D.C. THAT DAY.
I THOUGHT FOR EVERYTHING HE'S
DONE FOR US, IF THIS IS THE ONLY
THING HE IS GOING TO ASK OF ME,
I'LL DO IT.
>> WE'RE GOING TO WALK DOWN TO
THE CAPITOL.
>> DO YOU RECALL PRESIDENT TRUMP
MENTIONING GOING TO THE CAPITOL
DURING HIS SPEECH?
>> OH, YES.
>> Reporter: I'M JOINED BY CNN'S
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT SARA
MURRAY.
WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED ABOUT THESE
POSSIBLE CRIMINAL REFERRALS?
>> LOOK.
YOU LAID OUT THE THREE POTENTIAL
CHARGES WE ARE LEARNING ABOUT.
THAT MAY NOT BE ALL.
THERE MAY BE MORE THAN THAT THEY
REFER TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WHEN IT COMES TO TRUMP.
WHAT WE ARE REALLY LOOKING FOR
IS A LOT OF THE UNDERLYING
EVIDENCE THEY PUT OUT TO SUPPORT
THE CHARGES.
SOME OF THOSE YOU LAID OUT THERE
LIKE TALKING ABOUT OBSTRUCTION,
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CONSPIRACY.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
PURSUED WHEN IT COMES TO THE
RIOTERS WHO STORMED THE CAPITOL
THAT DAY.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
LIKE INSURRECTION THAT IS A MUCH
MORE COMPLICATED CHARGE SO WE'LL
BE LOOKING AT WHAT THE COMMITTEE
LAYS OUT AS EVIDENCE.
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE ON
MONDAY IS WHAT LAWMAKERS HAVE
BEEN SAYING SEPARATELY AS ONE
VOICE FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WE'VE HEARD INDIVIDUALLY FROM A
NUMBER OF LAWMAKERS WHO SAID
THEY BELIEVE THAT DONALD TRUMP
COMMITTED A CRIME WHEN IT CAME
TO WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th
THEY BELIEVE HE WAS CULPABLE.
AND NOW THIS IS THEIR ABILITY TO
REALLY LAY THAT OUT.
AGAIN, THIS IS LARGELY SYMBOLIC.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DOES NOT
TAKE ITS CUES FROM CONGRESS BUT
LAWMAKERS HAVE SAID THEY BELIEVE
THEY FOUND EVIDENCE CRIMES WERE
COMMITTED AND IT MAY NOT STOP
WITH JUST THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
THEY THINK THEY NEED TO LAY IT
OUT FOR THE HISTORICAL RECORD
AND FOR THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
>> WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT WHAT
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS GOT ACCESS
TO AND WHAT IT MIGHT MEAN FORTHE
JANUARY 6 INVESTIGATION?
>> THIS IS INTERESTING.
A CRIMINAL COURT FILING THAT
JUST BECAME PUBLIC, WE ARE
LEARNING FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS
HAVE ACCESSED E-MAIL ACCOUNTS,
MORE THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOCUMENTS, AND A BOOK OUTLINE
ALL PERTAINING TO COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
SCOTT PERRY, FORMER DOJ
OFFICIALS JEFFREY CLARK AND KEN
KLUKOWSKI AS WELL AS ATTORNEY
JOHN EASTMAN AND GETS INTO THEIR
DISCUSSIONS AROUND THE 2020
ELECTION.
JEFFREY CLARK WAS PENNING AN
OUTLINE FOR A BOOK ABOUT HIS
EXPERIENCES AROUND THE 2020
ELECTION.
WE NOW KNOW FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS HAVE THIS.
THIS IS A WEALTH OF INFORMATION.
IT GIVES YOU AN IDEA HOW DEEP
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS ARE GOING
INTO THIS.
THE OTHER THING, WE ARE JUST
LEARNING ABOUT THIS NOW BECAUSE
A VERSION BECAME UNSEALED.
BUT THIS IS WHAT PROSECUTORS
HAVE BEEN LOOKING INTO MONTHS
AGO.
THAT IS SOMETHING ELSE TO
REMEMBER AS WE GET GOING MONDAY
IS THAT WE HEAR WHAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS TO SAY.
PROSECUTORS ARE ALREADY VERY FAR
DOWN THIS ROAD WHEN IT COMES TO
INVESTIGATING DONALD TRUMP, HIS
ALLIES, AND WHAT WAS GOING ON IN
THE RUN UP TO JANUARY 6th.
>>> I'M JOINED BY OUR CHIEF
POLITICAL ANALYST GLORIA BERGER,
JOHN DEAN, AND SENIOR ELLIOTT
ANALYST.
GLORIA, HOW SIGNIFICANT WOULD IT
BE FOR A FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO BE REFERRED TO
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR
CRIMINAL CHARGES?
>> IT IS HISTORICALLY
SIGNIFICANT AND MEANINGFUL
BECAUSE WHEN YOU TAKE A STEP
BACK AND THINK ABOUT WHAT THESE
CRIMINAL REFERRALS ARE, THEY ARE
SAYING, A FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, WHILE HE WAS
IN OFFICE, WAS EFFECTIVELY
TRYING TO ORCHESTRATE A COUP,
TRYING TO FRAUDULENTLY CHANGE AN
ELECTION, SO HE COULD REMAIN IN
OFFICE.
IT IS KIND OF REMARKABLE.
OTHER CHARGES, OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS OF COURSE, CONSPIRACY
TO DEFRAUD THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT.
THE FACT IS, HOWEVER, AND I
THINK CLEARLY THIS WAS REFERRED
TO, IS THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
DOES NOT SAY, OKAY.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO.
BUT THIS CRIMINAL REFERRAL IS TO
SAY TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC, THIS
IS WHAT WE BELIEVE AFTER OUR
VOLUMINOUS HEARINGS AND
INVESTIGATIONS AND WE ARE
HANDING THIS MATERIAL OVER TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
LET THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DECIDE WHETHER OR IF TO CHARGE
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WITH ANY OF
THESE CHARGES.
SO I THINK THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT DOESN'T NEED TO GET
UP TO SPEED.
WE HAVE SEEN WITH HUNDREDS OF
PROSECUTIONS OF PEOPLE STORMING
THE CAPITOL THEY'VE ALREADY
STARTED IN THAT SENSE.
AND THEY ARE CLEARLY LOOKING AT
DONALD TRUMP AND A LOT OF HIS
COULD BE COCONSPIRATORS.
>> ELLIOTT, DOES THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT CARE WHETHER THEY
HAVE A CRIMINAL REFERRAL?
I MEAN IT IS NOT A REAL THING.
>> YOU KNOW, ANDERSON, I'D GO
EVEN FURTHER SAYING, TALKING
ABOUT CARING, I ACTUALLY THINK A
CRIMINAL REFERRAL GETS IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S WAY A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE IT
POLITICIZES THE WORK OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT EVEN ASSUMING
CONGRESS IS RIGHTEOUS IN WHAT
THEY'RE PURSUING WITH THE
CRIMINAL REFERRAL THERE IS STILL
A PARTISAN ELECTED BODY.
AND EVEN A BIPARTISAN COMMITTEE
OF CONGRESS IS STILL A POLITICAL
BODY THAT SORT OF PUTS THE THUMB
ON THE SCALE OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
SO IMAGINE IF THEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT PROCEEDS WITH CHARGES
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE PURSUED
ANYWAY, THERE IS AT LEAST THAT
QUESTION THAT THEY WERE SPURRED
TO DO WHAT THEY DO ON ACCOUNT OF
THE ACT BY CONGRESS.
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER.
AGAIN, AS I'VE SAID ON YOUR
PROGRAM BEFORE, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WILL PROCEED
REGARDLESS OF WHAT CONGRESS DOES
BUT IT DOES PUT THEM IN A
SOMEWHAT TRICKY POSITION OF
HAVING TO AT LEAST ANSWER THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER THEIR
PROSECUTION WAS POLITICAL.
>> JOHN, WHEN IT COMES TO
CHARGES BEING CONSIDERED,
OBSTRUCTION OF OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING AND INSURRECTION AND
DEFRAUDING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IF THE DOJ WERE TO PURSUE THOSE
HOW HIGH IS THE BAR IN THE COURT
OF LAW.
>> OF COURSE IT HAS TO BE PROVED
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT IN
FEDERAL COURT IN A CRIMINAL
PROCEEDING LIKE THIS AND THAT IS
THE HIGHEST STANDARD OF PROOF.
UNLIKE THIS COMMITTEE WHICH IS
RELYING ON HEARSAY ON OCCASIONS,
THEY HAVE TO GET TO THE SOURCE
OF EVERYTHING.
THEY DO HAVE THE TOOLS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO DO
THAT.
SOMETHING THE COMMITTEE DOESN'T.
NATURALLY THEY DO RELY ON
HEARSAY BECAUSE THEY TRUST THE
SOURCE THEY'RE GETTING IT FROM.
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN AT
JUSTICE IS MUCH DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT HAPPENED AT THE COMMITTEE
BUT THIS COMMITTEE IS TAKING
SUCH AN HISTORIC LOOK AT THE
PRESIDENCY AT SUCH AN IMPORTANT
TIME, THAT I THINK THEIR WORK IS
REALLY GOING TO BE REMEMBERED
LONG, LONG AFTER MONDAY.
>> GLORIA, HOW DOES THIS IMPACT,
ASSUMING THE COMMITTEE MAKES A
REFERRAL, HOW DOES IT IMPACT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND HIS ALLEGED
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN?
>> WELL IF HE WERE OUT
CAMPAIGNING HE MIGHT BE TALKING
ABOUT IT AND CLAIMING HE WERE
THE VICTIM BUT SINCE HE IS NOT
OUT CAMPAIGNING VERY MUCH I
DON'T KNOW HOW IT WILL AFFECT
HIS CAMPAIGN.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN, ANDERSON, IN
OUR POLL THIS WEEK, THAT 6 OF 10
REPUBLICANS, AND HE IS POPULAR
WITH REPUBLICANS, BUT 6 OF 10
REPUBLICANS ARE SAYING, YOU
KNOW, MAYBE WE OUGHT TO THINK OF
SOMEONE ELSE.
THIS IS JUST ONE MORE THING
PILED ON TOP OF LOTS OF OTHER
THINGS, THE MAR-A-LAGO
INVESTIGATION BEING ONE, FOR
EXAMPLE, BUT I THINK REPUBLICANS
ARE STARTING TO KIND OF LOOK FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE.
BECAUSE THEY'RE TIRED OF THIS.
>> ELLIOTT, IS THERE A SENSE FOR
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OF A
TIMELINE?
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T KNOW THE
DETAILS OF WHERE THEY ARE AT IN
THEIR INVESTIGATION.
IT SEEMS TO BE RAMPING UP.
THEY WILL GET ALL THE
INFORMATION I ASSUME ONCE IT IS
MADE PUBLIC THAT THE SELECT
COMMITTEE HAS, SO ANY SENSE OF
HOW LONG AN INVESTIGATION COULD
GO ON FOR?
>> THE OFFICIAL ANSWER IS FIVE
YEARS FROM THE COMMISSION OF THE
OFFENSE, THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR MOST CRIME.
THAT IS HOW LONG THEY HAVE
LEGALLY IN WHICH TO DO IT.
THE PROBLEM IS YOU JUST RUN INTO
A POLITICAL CALENDAR AND THINGS
CHANGE.
FOR INSTANCE A NEW JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT COULD CERTAINLY STOP
OR SUSPEND ANY OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT ARE ON GOING
NOW.
CERTAINLY ANYTHING WILL TAKE AT
LEAST A YEAR TO GET TO TRIAL OR
SEVERAL MONTHS TO GET TO TRIAL.
IF YOU TALK ABOUT AN
INSURRECTION CHARGE WHICH
PROBABLY ISN'T HAPPENING GIVEN
HOW RARELY IT HAS BEEN CHARGED
IN AMERICAN HISTORY IT WOULD
TAKE SEVERAL MONTHS TO A YEAR TO
GET TO TRIAL TO BEGIN WITH.
SO RIGHT THERE THEY ARE UP
AGAINST A BIT OF A CLOCK.
I WOULD ASSUME IF CHARGES ARE
COMING THEY WOULD PROBABLY HAVE
TO COME PRETTY SOON BECAUSE
FOLKS WORKING AT HEADQUARTERS OF
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AREN'T
DUMMIES AND THEY KNOW THEY
AREN'T BLESSED WITH UNLIMITED
TIME.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO JOHN
EASTMAN'S E-MAILS WHAT DOES THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT LOOK FOR
THERE?
>> APPARENTLY THEY ARE
CONSTANTLY FINDING NEW ONES,
LOOKING TO SEE WHAT KIND OF
ADVICE HE WAS GIVING.
DID HE KNOW IT WAS BOGUS ADVICE?
APPARENTLY THERE IS SOME
INDICATION HE DID.
THAT HE KNEW IT WOULDN'T SURVIVE
IN ANY COURT OF LAW.
SO HE WAS TELLING THE PRESIDENT
TO DO THINGS THAT WERE NOT
WITHIN THE BALANCE OF THE LAW.
HE WAS PUSHING EXAMPLES THAT
WERE REALLY NOT GOOD LEGAL
ADVICE.
HE WAS ACTUALLY A MEMBER OF A
CONSPIRACY WHERE HE WAS NOT
DOING ANYTHING TO DISTANCE
HIMSELF FROM THOSE ILLEGAL
ACTIVITIES B